[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to the MIT
Center for Art, Science,
and Technology's
2021 symposium--
Unfolding Intelligence,
the Art and Science
of Contemporary Computation.
CAST was established
in 2012 with the goal
of building and
building on connections
between the worlds of art,
science, and technology.
This is the third in
a series of symposia
that CAST has convened
since then, and as
with its predecessors, we bring
together artists, scientists,
engineers, and humanists
from within MIT
and from the world
at large to discuss
areas of rapidly
evolving research
and urgent social relevance.
And defined in that dialogue--
stimulation, confirmation,
provocation, intersection,
and we hope common purpose.
At MIT, CAST partners with
departments, labs, and centers
to integrate the arts
across the curriculum,
to enrich and encourage artistic
collaboration, and to provide
support to faculty and
members of the MIT community
as they pursue their
own artistic practice
and/or research.
In addition to
symposia like this,
CAST facilitates the sharing
of this creative work
beyond the Institute
by producing concerts,
exhibitions, and
publications and making
them available to the public.
So thank you for
being with us today.
We hope you will join
us throughout the week
at virtual events addressing
the aesthetic, technical,
and critical issues pertaining
to artificial intelligence
and computational media.
We also look forward to seeing
you on Friday, April 9th,
as the symposium culminates
with a live interactive event
to which all
attendees are invited,
and which you can join
presenters and artists
in breakout rooms to explore
hidden threads between all that
has been discussed this week.
Hello.
Welcome to the Q&A for
the Unfolding Models
panel of the Unfolding
Intelligence symposium.
I'm professor of anthropology
Stefan Helmreich,
and I'm thrilled to
join you with the three
exceptional speakers
for our session, who
are Princeton University
physicist and professor
of astronomy Priya
Natarajan; Yale University
professor in ecology and
evolutionary biology, Brandon
Ogbunu; and glitch artist
and resolution theorist Rosa
Menkman.
And I hope you've
been able to watch
their really quite
riveting presentations
over this last weekend.
Before we start up on this
hour long conversation, which
I'm really looking
forward to, I want
to thank all of the people
involved in the symposium--
CAST faculty director
Professor Evan Ziporyn;
executive director of arts
initiatives Leila Kinney;
my fellow conveners, Will
[INAUDIBLE],, Caroline Jones.
I also want to thank
the CAST producers--
Dana, Heidi, Leah, Kathryn,
Susan, Lydia, and Harriet--
for all of the incredible work
that they've done supporting us
in this insanely complex
communications and logistics
involved in today's event.
And thanks also to Drew for
providing ASL interpretation
today.
So much work.
I also want to
acknowledge that MIT
sits on the traditional unceded
territory of the Wampanoag
Nation, traditional
stewards of this land.
And I want to note,
too, that offering
an acknowledgment like this,
through the data clouds
and cables that we're
talking through,
is also to recognize
all of the computer
models of communication that
[INAUDIBLE] the unfolding
of our conversation itself.
So Unfolding-- this
is a panel about how
tools and computations shape
the models that scientists
and artists make of the
universe, the world,
and of models themselves.
And I want to revisit and frame
some of the arguments delivered
by our panelists,
whom, if I can,
I would like to have
join me on the screen.
I think there's magic
that can make that happen.
So just to refresh
folks' memories
about our presentations and
set us up for discussion,
Priya Natarajan
told us how she uses
computer simulations to
explore the black hole growth
problem in cosmology.
With simulations understood as
what she very usefully calls,
playing a mediatory
role between theory
and observation--
a mediatory role.
And more as
potentially generative
of new explanation, new
evidence, new knowledge,
and prediction.
So she argued that
simulations may
be approached as a kind
of creolized language
for communicating in domains
that are simultaneously
experimental, theoretical, and
observational, so simulations
become tools for signification
that may be understood as what
she-- as activating
what she calls
an interglot, a
mix of languages.
An interglot-- this is one
of our key words, interglot.
Dr. Ogbunu took the analytic
of unfolding in his paper
and really ran with it,
making, first, the connection
to protein folding
and protein unfolding,
and then to a really, I
think, inspired connection
to unfolding as disentangling
via Darwin's image,
famous image of the tangled
bank, which then also
immediately got us to the
questions of the entanglement
of science and society--
genetically modified organisms,
gene editing, et cetera.
And he argued that
disentangling biological process
requires models.
Model's the central dogma
in molecular biology--
DNA makes RNA makes protein--
and models that
also have to operate
at the right level
for the question
that they're answering.
So a model of the COVID-19
pandemic, for example,
will be operating at various
levels for different purposes.
Maybe a level of
protein expression,
maybe to a level of
population dynamics,
maybe to a level
that embraces things
to do with social inequality
and structural racism.
And he got us to think about
how models as instruments,
and also, I think, importantly,
as structures of analogy,
so disentangling analogies.
We want to think about
how models help us express
analogies, but also
demand that we disentangle
the analogies that we use.
Yeah, which analogies do we use?
I mean, is evolution a game?
Is evolution an algorithm?
Those kinds of questions
go into deciding
how to model what it is.
And Rosa Menkman tells us that
our media, the media on which
we do computer simulations, come
to us not only with promises
to represent, replicate,
record, and extend
sense experience of the
world, but also come
to us in a range of formats--
cassette tapes,
A4 paper, JPEGs--
but also in [? material. ?]
They come to us
in material manifestations
which have their own limits
and their own affordances
in the resolutions
that they can offer
us, resolutions
that are then animated through
the kinds of compression
protocols that are used for
relaying something like an MP3
or JPEG, and that can glitch
in really interesting ways
that are sometimes disturbing,
sometimes inspiring, sometimes
productive.
And so I think,
when I'm supposed--
I should have one of
these for this, too.
Here we go, compression glitch.
I also have this
book, Glitch Feminism.
There's all kinds of
glitches around my desk.
So we learn through all of
this that computer models
are interglots.
They are instruments.
They're analogical
machines, and they are also
dependent upon standards which
are technical and political,
standards that demand particular
kinds of compressions,
and that produce
artifacts in two senses--
artifacts as things, and
then artifacts as things
you don't want.
And I guess we want to
talk about all of that.
The way that I want to organize
this conversation, just
to start us off--
and we'll also be taking
questions from the audience
later on.
But just to start us off, I want
to take each of our panelists
in turn and pose to them
questions that are inspired
by the other panelists.
So if I can, I'd love
to turn to you, Priya,
to talk about this really
interesting work you're
doing on the black hole
growth problem in cosmology
and thinking about that through
simulations that mean to match,
in scale, the observational
data that you have
from various telescopes and
how they do that using machine
learning algorithms.
But I guess, after watching
Brandon's presentation, which
offers that models may
be seen as instruments,
I wondered whether you
thought of interglots,
about which you can say more--
whether you thought of
inerglots as, themselves, kinds
of instruments?
So maybe do that?
Pick that up, if you like.
Thanks, Stefan.
Thanks.
I think I want to,
first, clarify that
when I am talking
about simulations,
I am setting these cosmological
simulations apart in many ways
compared to other ways,
numerically visualizing data
and processes and
equations and so on.
And the reason for that, as
I've argued in the presentation,
was that cosmology is
a very peculiar field.
We cannot perform any kind
of controlled experiments,
laboratory experiment
or whatever.
What you have in the
universe is what you get.
So we visually record
and make observations,
and then we have
to interpret them
in the context of
some conceptual model.
And these conceptual models
used to be paper and pencil
equations, and we're
also very lucky that we
have the ordered
physical laws that
give us a structure and a
frame to do the interpretation.
And increasingly, when
you can't do anything
on pencil and paper, you've
needed computer simulations,
and so that's how
simulations were originally
seen as being merely
enhancing and not generative
of new discoveries.
I mean, also, there's the
philosophical awkwardness
that you are sitting
inside the universe
that you are observing, so there
isn't this traditional distance
between the observer
and the observed, other
than the quantum
funniness aside.
In classical physics, that is
a very important assumption
because that's tied in with
other [INAUDIBLE] concepts
like objectivity and
so on and so forth.
So here we are-- we're sitting
in the middle of this universe.
We're making observations.
And there is only one
universe, so I can't actually
replicate it either.
So in many ways, cosmology's
not really a science
as traditionally defined,
and therefore, simulations
play a very important role.
And so I've argued that they
play the mediatory role of--
and they are an interglot
because they are actually
universal in the sense
that, now, simulations
allow you to connect models and
theories to observational data
directly, except there
are some limitations.
As you pointed out, the
fact that we are not
able to replicate,
in our simulations,
the exact survey volumes
that are observationally
accessible to us with our
telescopes at the moment,
and this is where machine
learning comes in.
And so there have been two
instances, only two instances,
where simulations
have actually been
generative of new knowledge.
One is a very
interesting instance,
which is the firm
Double Negative that
did the visualization for
the movie Interstellar.
So they actually saw
Einstein's [INAUDIBLE],,
and what they
found, they found--
and [INAUDIBLE],, who has
been working in this field,
a Nobel laureate, one of the big
figures in understanding black
hole physics--
he noticed, in
the visualization,
that there was a
non-linearity that he had not
picked up before.
So there's actually a scientific
paper on which people from
Double Negative have authored.
So that's the one
case that I really
know where a simulation
has been generative,
something that was completely
unanticipated, unseen before.
And the second
example is the one
that I gushed on about in
my talk, where we recently
realized, from just
looking at simulations,
that there ought to be a very
large population of wandering
black holes in the universe,
and a handful, one or two,
have been found
because, normally, we
expect all these black
holes to be anchored
to the centers of galaxies,
like our own galaxy harbors
a dormant black hole, and so on.
So I think the relationship
between models,
speaking to Brandon's work--
so this relationship between
models and observational data
for cosmology is somewhat
apart and slightly different.
And I would also kind of clarify
that it's not quite a creole.
It is like a universal
glot, so it's
an interglot in that sense.
Creole is very
specific [INAUDIBLE]
target languages if
I'm not mistaken,
so this time [INAUDIBLE]
is much more universal.
It so happens to--
And as for the untangling that
both Rosa and Brandon talked
about, that you wanted
me to connect to,
I think what I found
really interesting is
the way in which we
conceptualize models,
whether it's a primary visual
representation of the model.
I mean, I think in
physics, we have
this added advantage that we
have mathematical equations
that offer--
and laws, these
tight correlations
and cause and effect, which
are very clearly defined.
So what I found
really intriguing is
to hear from two
people in two fields
where causality is not-- for
us, causality is a constraint.
I mean, the cause happens
before the effect,
and you can actually draw
a line and connect the dots
because you have these
principles, these universal law
of gravitation, et
cetera, et cetera.
So it's very interesting to see
Rosa's work and Brandon's work,
where there aren't necessarily
such clear cut joining
the dots.
In Rosa's case, you
probably impose that by hand
by choosing to compress
the data, decompress
and compress the data, alter
the resolution, and so on.
Well, thank you for that.
I mean, that-- again,
go ahead, Rosa.
Yeah, I enjoy this bridge to
what you're talking about,
and in this case, I would
say it connects mostly
towards the blob that I ended
the video with, which I use
also as a tool, I would say.
It's a tool to not only show how
image making works-- and a part
of that is compression.
I wouldn't say that's
the only thing.
Resolution setting has a lot
of stuff involved, whether it's
the CCD chip or the aperture or
the amount of energy invested
in the machine that
is making the image.
So in that case, this blob is
this metaphoric latent space
for any possible image,
and you cut it away,
and I think there's an
analogy to your research
also, where you're
talking about affordances.
I see these affordances
are axes that got the blob,
and they cut away compromises.
So the compromises
are the images
that are no longer being made
because you set a resolution.
I think you used
the word for that.
I'm trying to find
it real quick.
Do you remember this
word that you used?
I think it was a
very interesting--
I did use resolution.
I did use resolution in a
slightly different sense
in terms of--
when I was talking
more about the limits,
Rosa, which I think
you also come to.
When you're talking
about the blob,
you are talking about sort of
the limits of understanding
of what is possible.
Yeah, I think [INAUDIBLE]--
input assumptions.
That's what I'm
talking about even.
That's what you're
saying, and I think
input assumptions are
a very interesting way
to frame-- it's the same idea,
but for me, I use the word
affordance, I guess.
Well, maybe I can
bring Brandon in here.
I'm really interested in this
question that you brought up,
Brandon, about the level at
which abstractions operate
in models, which to use
Rosa's term just now,
involves a set of compromises.
In order to decide
that a phenomenon is
made of particular levels,
you have to compromise.
So I wonder if you can
speak a little bit more
about that question
of how you think
through the levels at which
the models you write operate.
Maybe I'll just start
asking to start there.
I've got more, but--
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I think--
thank you for that question.
Fabulous interaction already.
Very, very fun to explore
the connections here.
I think what's
interesting and fun
about talking about the
levels of a model question
is that it really does
invoke [INAUDIBLE] expertise
in the art part of modeling.
That's actually where the
imagination enters it.
That's where
understanding enters it,
and this is why the notion
of simply having students,
for example, learn just a
suite of mathematical and
computational techniques
is the end all
be all to being
able to understand,
for example, what underlies
the COVID-19 pandemic.
And this is where a lot of
the problems of modeling
a complex system
comes from, is that we
have an infinite number--
a lot of different tools we
can use to examine phenomena,
but we aren't clear about
what the question actually is.
And we have to be clear about
what the question actually
is to build the proper model
to address that question.
So like I talk
about in the talk,
with regards to the
electrons in the calculator,
let's just take an
epidemic, for example.
I mean, I could
understand everything
about the way proteins fold.
Let's just say we
completely solve
that problem, one that's very,
very modern and cutting edge.
I mean, that could tell you
absolutely nothing about
whether or not a vaccine
is going to be effective.
That's a completely different
question at a societal level.
It's a completely
different question,
requires a completely different
level of understanding
and requires a
different model in order
to address that question.
I think we can walk that
over into every single one
of these problems.
Certainly, in physics,
and it's very humbling
to be on the stage
with a physicist
because I think a lot of
the modelers in my field
wish they were physics,
the physics envy concept.
I think we've borrowed from
this tradition of being
able to understand
the world in terms
of a set of analytical
descriptions,
and what we're finding is
that those are powerful,
but you do require this other
dimension in understanding
and art and insight
in order to be
able to capture a biological
phenomenon in a meaningful way.
So just to summarize, I mean,
I think that level of question
is one that is
humbling, but I think
that is where the creativity,
the domain expertise, and study
and these types
of things really,
really do separate the good
models from the bad ones,
and we're seeing this
play out in phenomenon
like the pandemic.
Yeah, can I ask you
more about that?
Since we do have here as an
evolutionary biologist who
thinks a lot about epidemiology
and its various entailments,
how would you
classify and evaluate
the levels at which the COVID-19
epidemic models are operating?
What are the levels--
Great question--
[INAUDIBLE] Go ahead.
Well, great question, and I
think now, as of April 2021,
I think all of the
levels of models
are operating to address
different questions.
But let's go a year ago.
I think it's fun to think about
this as a chronological thing
because, early on, we were quite
interested in how mutation A
and mutation B were playing
together on the [INAUDIBLE]
protein, and whether
or not that allows--
whether that means the vaccine
will be effective or not.
We wanted to know the basic
shape of the epidemic,
and of course, you know this
better than anyone, Stefan,
with regards to the
shape and the wave
analogies and these things
that you've pioneered.
We wanted to know
the basic shape.
How bad is this
thing going to be?
How fast before
we get to A and B?
How long do we need
to be under lockdown?
Those are macro scale questions.
In order to understand
that, you need
to some kind of
gross properties,
and the debate about
this [INAUDIBLE] thing,
which is now common knowledge,
this parameter that we
use to understand how contagious
a pathogen is, for example.
It's now common knowledge.
But the idea here is this allows
us to give a general character
and shape about the
way an epidemic looks,
and that allowed us to make big
national and social policies.
That's where the debate really
still is there in some ways,
about what we should do and
when we should open and when we
shouldn't.
But that defined
the early window,
and that's one level at
which models are useful.
So the early UK
model, for example,
that talked about a
couple of million dead,
and these predictions that
were very, very dire if we
don't do anything in a hurry.
I mean, that's been debated,
but that was at one level.
I think, now, we're at
a much different level,
or rather, our models
include other levels.
And they are about
things like whether
or not we can expect the vaccine
to be effective against the UK
strain or the Brazil
strain or the [INAUDIBLE]..
That's a completely
different question.
What's interesting and fun to
this point about interglots
that Priya's present--
what an amazing term
that I'm certainly
going to take moving forward.
What a brilliant way
of thinking about it.
It's connecting
these two things.
It's connecting the levels.
And so models can
allow you to do that.
You can build a model about
the molecular evolution
of the virus at
the protein level,
and you can ask a question
now about the way that--
how can we think
about vaccinology
across a population over
the next several months?
We can actually build
bridges between these things.
So I find that to be--
we had to arrive there, though.
It took us time.
I just wanted to make
a very quick point.
This is just
absolutely fascinating,
and I think what is
remarkable about this panel
and the themes are how well
all of the different strands
and types that we all
used to think converge.
And so the COVID
question, for example,
for me, from what
Brendan has outlined
and Stefan's work
and Rosa's work--
I mean, don't you
guys think this
was one of the absolute
exemplars of the provisionality
of science?
We really don't even
know, as Brendan said,
what is the right
question to ask?
What are all the
right questions?
And we've seen all
these various modelers
coming in with their
inherent biases,
wanting to focus on
one particular question
without realizing that no
one question can be isolated
in something like the pandemic?
This is a network.
There are all these
questions that all
have to be tackled
together, and it's not
like you have, there's
one equation for spread,
that that's all
we needed to get,
and that would
resolve everything.
No, this is a very
complex problem,
and I thought this was one
of those classic cases where
you see the process of science
and the provisionality.
We know as much as we
know at any given point,
and then we have to, as Brandon
said and as Rosa points out,
we have to, without limit,
keep asking questions
because we don't even know
what the right questions are
and which all questions
need to be answered
to find the solution,
solution being how
do we survive this as a globe.
[? TRANSCRIPT BREAK ?]
I think this is so interesting.
I haven't thought about
the pandemic in such a way,
but I would say what
you're proposing
is almost that the pandemic is
a scenario in which scientists
could almost have a real-life
test scenario in which they can
communicate, and open up their
knowledge to the normal public,
which is something
people like me-- artists,
artistic researchers-- do.
That's my job, basically.
I do research, but
I don't convey it
to the scientific
community per se.
I convey it to a normal
audience that watches art.
So it needs to be like--
there is a basic necessity
to make it accessible,
and people wanting to access it.
And what Brandon is
also saying, we're
missing kind of a
translational aesthetics here.
And as you're also pointing out
with the Kip Thorne example,
where the artistic director
of a movie about the shadow
of a black horse only
finds a piece of science
by showing it through
their [? renders. ?]
What's really interesting, and
what's been really interesting,
is that what I've seen
throughout my research
is that there is a very deep
relationality between Hollywood
aesthetics and aesthetics
of science and programming.
Because programming being
Silicon Valley and Hollywood
being in LA, those are places
that are almost next door.
And these people actually
come and visit each other.
They conversate.
Is this study, is this
way of showing this,
is the proper way to do it?
And then there is a
scientific aesthetic exchange.
This has been happening.
But at this point now,
we're seeing, as you already
pointed out, that there's people
from all over the disciplines
that all think that their
one particular question is
the question to answer the
problem of the pandemic.
But they need to voice this.
And so what we're seeing is that
there is not enough bridges.
There's not enough
[? interglottery ?]
to voice the problems in
between research fields.
What I would propose, because
I'm actually quite worried
about just an interglot,
because to me,
it becomes very
closely connected
to a newspeak of sciences.
Because newspeak is
this 1984 reference
to George Orwell, where they're
creating this one language that
takes out all the
metaphoric speak
because now we have one word
to capture a particular state.
This one-on-one idea of
translation, I do hope--
and I think that's
what you are also for--
is that there is still
this metaphoric analogous
poetic space in the interglot.
And maybe there is some
space for an extraglot,
in that sense.
So I think that one other
interesting thread that I
see in this mentioned,
one of the reasons
the pandemic has been
so problematic, aside
from the impact on our lives,
is the reaction of the public.
The fact that the science
was evolving in real time,
our understanding limited by
the questions, as Brandon said,
limited by the level at
which we want to solve.
And so people are
seeing the uncertainty
in science, proportionality
and uncertainty.
Because people were
supposedly baffled,
when we were saying no masks
today and then tomorrow,
you're saying masks.
We don't know.
All of this is changing.
And I think this is the peril of
getting into unknown territory,
moving into unknown territory.
And what are the sort of
metaphorical connections,
and as Brandon said, the levels
and the kinds of connections
that we have to
simultaneously be aware of?
And to me, it seems
like for the pandemic,
it might have been
interesting to have started
off thinking of how to
approach this pandemic
and modeling it as a crosses
disciplinary adventure
right from the beginning,
instead of focusing
on the people who are
modeling contagions,
providing different models, and
then the public health people
chiming in as a result,
reacting to the model.
So I'd be curious to hear all
of you talk about the reactions
to models.
I mean, why isn't the
modeling more integrative?
Just for a brief--
just to jump in,
and I know there's a
lot of COVID fatigue,
and we wouldn't want to
spend the whole time talking
about that example, but I must
say to connect these points,
I think for all the negatives
and all the things that
were botched-- and I've
written a lot about them
and I think Priya, you
mentioned a lot about the amount
the problems we have.
I think a positive example of
particularly where the arts was
very central in a
positive response
was the Flatten the
Curve movement, which
was a data visualization that
was created by a data artist.
And flattening the curve became
a social justice rallying cry.
It became an epidemiological
rallying cry.
And it really defined the
positive part of the response.
And that was not invoked or
created by scientists at all.
Well, it was somebody who
was a data visualization
person that ended up driving
this public health campaign.
So I think to the
point you just made,
Priya, that type
of good example--
and that is a model.
There's no numbers in it,
but it is a model in the ways
that we talk about.
And it is a model,
certainly, the way
that Rosa has mentioned with
regards to how the arts can
drive and kind of
reframe how we can
think about complex problems.
I would expand
that to include it
as an interglot, that
kind of synthesis.
Yeah, I mean,
thanks for bringing
that up, Brandon, because
I was going to think of--
precisely following Rosa--
think about the politics
and the possible pitfalls
of aesthetic productions
of scientific knowledge
in visualization.
The curve has done a
lot of really good work,
but it also obscures things.
I mean, it obscures the
multiplicity of curves.
It did for a while,
I think for many,
obscure the radically
different experiences
different communities
had, where one
had to realize there are
many, many curves happening.
And some of the
curves are revelatory
of things like
structural racism,
underserved public
health infrastructure,
things like that.
But I think that's
super interesting
to think about that piece
of scientific visualization
as producing an aesthetics
that does and does not
surface particular kinds
of matters of concern.
I want to get back to
aesthetics and ask Rosa
a question about aesthetics.
And I want to ask you
what your experience was
of watching the talks by Priya
and Brandon in terms of that.
What kinds of aesthetic
trends did you
see kind of coursing through the
way they presented their talks?
Maybe you have some
kind of glitch radar.
What kinds of glitches did
you see that might possibly
leap into their work
unannounced or things
like that, if that makes sense.
Honestly, I didn't
see any glitches.
Also, I have to say I
appreciate glitches.
I think we are diluting the
word "glitch" a little bit here.
A glitch would be an unexpected
break from an expected
flow or a functional flow.
Of course, in
popular culture, this
has become something
more stylized
and it's been taken out of
the technological definition.
And now it's become
like a language,
a visual language of its own.
When I looked at Brandon
simply as a presentation,
I don't think there
was a lot of glitch
there whatsoever, not
from the stylized form
and definitely
not what I can say
for a scientific point of view.
You guys are perfect.
I mean, maybe another term to
put in here is "standards."
I mean, what kinds
of standards did you
see animating the
way the work had
to be kind of held together?
Well, what I like about
Priya's presentation,
but maybe that says more about
me than about scientific,
but maybe not--
when I was going through
her slides again,
I recognized a lot
of the images that I
use in my own presentations.
There was one slide that you
have three different images.
One was from the Big Bang
and the time after it.
There was the shadow of a
black hole, and another image.
And in my last
presentations, I've
been using those particular
images point blank.
So what I'm starting
to see is that there
are these tropes or images
that are maybe overused.
They become not just
an illustration,
they become the illustration.
And that's actually
dangerous, because then we
consider a black hole or
the shadow of a black hole,
in this case, to always
have these particular
[? floopsies ?] of
energy or whatever it is.
And I think that is dangerous
because maybe black holes are
not at all this round,
and also because these
are simulated images in
the sense that they have
been given color or whatever.
So for the non-educated
scientific interested person,
they might actually open up just
a standardized aesthetic that
makes them misunderstand that
these things are much more
wide in variety, and that
a lot of these things
can be colored differently,
be understood differently--
basically that what
you're looking at
are like energy
waves or sound waves
rather than a color, a shadow.
I don't know, whatever.
So that's a--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--very important point
you make, Rosa, and Stefan
for guiding her to that.
I think that these
images are meant
to structure our imagination.
But there is a fear they
will limit our imagination.
And we have to
watch out for that.
And I have something
to add to that, maybe.
When I was at CERN where I did
my Collider at CERN residency,
I was really looking
for imagery aesthetics
of particle physics, research
into the smallest, tiniest
bits.
And what I found was
that there was actually
very little artistic
interpretation of those places.
All you see are just the events
in a collision diagram or just
numbers.
And I was wondering
a lot of the times,
why is there so little
artistic interpretation
in a place like CERN?
And my conclusion was finally
that we don't actually
have a lot of movies taking
place at the particle physics
level.
So there is not that influx of
money, of artistic directors,
of research into how to open up
this space to another audience
which has, again, both positive
and negative consequences.
But so when I was
there, actually, I
believe it was
also Kip Thorne who
came to visit
because he was going
to make a movie about tiny
superheroes or something.
I don't know.
But that was really
funny to me, because I
think it's one of the first
times they had a Hollywood
director going to do research
on the tiny stuff, which
is something that there's not
a lot of imagination about,
that we all have to imagine
by ourselves somehow.
But I think in astronomy, we
have the advantage, thankfully,
that the sky
belongs to everyone.
And we all have experience.
We don't have to do much,
just existing, looking up,
being upright as Homo
sapiens, we've had access.
So I mean there's a connection
that anybody and everybody can
make to our visual images.
And there isn't the same kind of
visceral connection and access.
A child growing up in Kenya
looking up at the night
will see a better sky, actually,
than we do in New Haven,
for instance.
But you don't have the
same with particle physics.
There's a lot of layers
of interpretation,
computing, models, many layers
of many unfolded and folded
models that lie between us and
that representation of data
from particle accelerators.
And also, to use
Rosa's terms again,
there are compromises
built into the kinds
of theoretical commitments that
you want to make in the model.
I want to make sure we get
some time to get questions
from our audience.
And I have a couple here.
Maybe I'll start
with one to Brandon.
We have a question.
I'll read it.
It says, "You shared that
abstractions and metaphors are
how incomplete models
could be generative.
In your observations,
would these poetics
be challenging for
scientists to grasp?
What are your recommendations
for young scientists
to enhance competence in using
abstractions and metaphors
in modeling?"
That's a great question.
I think the challenge here is
the way that we teach science
and how that is incompatible
with a lot of the ideas
that I talked about with
regards to how abstractions
can be generative.
We teach people kind
of the analytical tools
to be able to understand,
in physics class,
the way a pendulum is swinging
or something of that nature,
which is a really
important thing
to understand because
those are kind
of fundamental forces
of the universe.
The problem is that
everything that is interesting
will not be neatly described
by those types of equations
that way.
And a great example,
one that I think
of when I connect
with Rosa's work,
is the whole problem
of modern genetics,
is one where we have
a complicated mess
of genetic information
interacting with environments
in all these essentially
infinitely complicated ways
to create me standing
here at what am I,
let's just round up to 6 foot 1.
And the idea that is composed
of all of this information
interacting right in this way.
And I think we're
limited in that way
by the manner in
which we have built
scientific knowledge,
which is 1 plus 1 equals 2,
and everything is very
linear and structure,
when in fact, it's this blob.
It's this tangled bank.
It's all of these
complicated things that
are interacting in one way.
So what I would say is, so how
do you actually address that?
It's that we really need--
I think the easy answer
is liberal arts education
or something like that.
But I think much more
nuanced than that,
the best models do
not require numbers.
And this is what
I say-- it starts
conceptual and artful first.
It doesn't matter
how complicated
the problem is, whether or
not it is Schrodinger's cat,
and I don't know how
Priya feels about that.
So maybe you don't
like that analogy.
But the point is, it's has
been useful for people to think
about a complicated problem,
whether it's the Punnett
Square, which is analogy,
whether it's the [? central ?]
[? dogma, ?] which
is an analogy,
whether it's another
one that Priya,
I want to hear you talk about,
the the Michelson-Morley,
whatever it is.
I think we really need to teach
abstract reasoning independent
of numbers or even scientific
principles at first,
and then use that to build
scientific knowledge on top of.
I practice this in
my research program.
And I think this is kind
of useful for young people.
Well, thank you
so much for that.
That really connects
well to a question
that's come in for
Rosa, precisely about
non-numerical representation.
The question is
about narratives.
So this is a question from
one of our viewers to Rosa,
and it reads, "Narratives
seem to be prominent
in your practice.
Could you further
elaborate how narratives
have helped enrich your
artistic research, especially
in exploring your subject
matters that are often
quite abstract, resolution,
and data, or even nonexistent.
This is your work about
impossible images.
How would you describe the
role of narratives for you
in formulating,
challenging, expanding
computationalist and
representationalist models?
Yeah, I have a twofold
answer to that and one part
I have actually already covered.
But when I was talking
to scientists at CERN,
one of the scientists told me
that to her, actually, science
is the challenge of
finding things out
and the pleasure
of understanding.
But then, of course,
as I am an artist
and I'm not writing a diary or
just doing research in my head
until I make a paper,
I want to put it
into legible or understandable
information to my audience.
But then there was
the second part
is where, when I was
visiting-- because that's
the beauty of the CERN
Award that I received
is that I didn't just
get to be at CERN
and talk to all the scientists
there, which was amazing.
I talked to 40
scientists, and I realized
that there are many types
of particle physicists.
There is not just one.
Every particle
physicist by themselves
already use another language
to talk about the same things.
And that depends if
they're philosophical
or more mathematically geared.
But to me as a newbie, as
somebody that is definitely not
of that realm, it became really
hard to follow their language
and to learn to probe what to
be able to expect from them.
And then it turns out, OK,
they have not one or four
big experiments,
but actually, they
have hundreds of experiments.
And all these experiments,
they perceive stuff
through technology.
Cool.
How do they perceive stuff?
They watch something,
whether it's
a wave, whether it's light--
or whether it's a light wave
or whether it's a sound or
whether it's an energy thing.
I don't know.
They watch all this stuff
going through something,
whether it's a magnet or
a lens, an optical lens.
They watch it through something.
They probe it through something
and then something comes out.
But some of these people, they
try to dumb it down for me
and try to make
it understandable.
And they talk about it
as photographic machines.
And then when I come
to the next scientist,
they get very upset if I say,
oh, so this part of the camera
is the lens.
They're, like, "This
is not a camera."
So what I realized is that
not just every scientist
has their own language.
These machines, they also
are generally called--
I don't know how to
say it-- referenced
to by different names.
And what I really
enjoyed by both Priya
and Brandon is that Priya,
you used "messengers."
And I would say
those messengers,
they go through a window that's
like the probing mechanism,
whereas in Brandon's talk,
you use the word "actors"
and "operators."
I'm not entirely sure if I can
conflate your two researches
through that, but
in my imagination,
if we have a latent image
space, or just a latent
image, or latent
space of perception,
or whatever it is, then
there are at least these two.
But now with machine learning,
it gets more complicated,
of course.
And that's very
interesting to me
but I don't know how
to expound on that yet.
But you get this window
messenger kind of situation
in every one of these
scientific spaces.
And that refers, again,
to your interglots, Priya,
but also maybe to Brandon.
I don't know if that's a good
answer to you, but that's--
It makes me wonder about
visual interglots, maybe.
One of the people
asking a question to us
revisits something we've
discussed a little bit,
but I think is worth
more discussion.
For Priya, they write,
"You've described
the profound potential
of simulations
and cosmological studies.
The simulated images you showed
are indeed very stunning.
Do visual parameters
in your simulation
serve both functionally
and aesthetically?
How do you decide on the
determination and altering
of visual elements
in your simulations,
like colors, scales,
textures, even
visual effects and animation?
And how do they affect
the modeling results?"
I'm thinking, too,
of Rosa's talk
pointing us to things like
the latent histories of race
in color photography,
which tells
on the very chemistry of
the way that film operated
in the mid 20th century.
So what about the visuals
that you give us, the colors
of the black holes, et cetera?
Right, so that's
a great question.
And I think that there
are choices that are made,
that are very specific
choices that are made.
And so there is intentionality
behind those choices.
And often, if they
are optimized,
as I mentioned, for
familiarity, because these
are very esoteric,
abstract kinds of objects
that you can't quite
reach out and touch.
And so there's a way in
which part of the exercise
is to make it intelligible
and accessible,
that is, to a visual palette
that anyone and everyone can
kind of appreciate.
So the fundamental
colors of heat--
the fact that it's white hot,
it's red hot, and yellow.
So that sort of
black-body spectrum
sort of informs
many of the choices.
And some of the
visualization is also
scientifically driven in
terms of the phenomenon
that I want to draw your
eye to and attention to.
So what do you choose
to show as dynamic?
Because one of the
problems in all
these simulations is the number
of enmeshed, embedded time
scales and spatial scales
that are all kind of lumped
together.
And in the universe,
when you go out at night
and you see a little,
wispy galaxy [? nearby, ?]
you're seeing a two-dimensional
projection of it.
And the advantage
of a simulation
is that we can give you the
experience of dancing around
it and seeing it in 3D,
which you never, ever see.
So it's a reconstruction.
So it's a simulation in
sort of the dictionary word.
If you go and look up the
word of a "simulation,"
there's something about
fakeness, make-believe,
that is part of that.
So there's that little
bit of that element.
But I wanted to come back
to this larger question
that everyone has
addressed so beautifully,
Stefan, which you
pointed out, which
is I think we need a sort
of a new kind of lexicon.
And my personal obsessions
are with mapping.
And so I think we don't, as
Brandon said and Rosa said,
we can have a new--
we can come up with
new kinds of alphabet.
I mean, it doesn't
have to be mathematics.
It doesn't have to be pre
models that already exist.
We can really think of
new kind of ways of--
it seems if you look at any
problem now, it's not so much--
the problems are no longer--
you can't force them
into linear bits.
It's all about networks
and interconnections.
So I think we need a
new lexicon that'll
allow you to map connections.
I don't know what it is.
[INAUDIBLE] people
like Rosa to help us,
help people like Brandon
and me to figure out
what might be optimal ways
of getting people to think,
both pedagogically
and otherwise.
What might be new ways of--
visual clearly, because
of the universal appeal
of visual elements.
Although I also would
argue colorblindness.
I also think of colorblindness
or think of the different kinds
of [INAUDIBLE],, or the fact
that luminosity and saturation
don't track the same in black
and white versus in color.
And so all these
interesting confusions
can happen when you move from
one coloring regime to another.
But I'll step back,
and Brandon, you were--
And the whole sort of inherent--
the whole idea of
in science, a lot
of these iconic methodologies--
there have been a very
small set of people
who have been able to do
science, who have got to define
science, who have
gotten to define
the symbolic value of science.
And the question is in
converging to universals,
there's always a danger
that we are drowning
out the multiplicity
and the creative energy
that different kinds of
individuals, different kinds
of systems bring.
So I think that is the
challenge of our times.
How do we actually move away
from the restricted visual
symbolic languages?
I know that Brandon
wants to add--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--anthropologist.
But I just want to say
maybe what you're both
getting at is that
most of our audiences
have become too lazy
because they're so
used to established
vernaculars and established
imagery for particular things.
So maybe what we need is
more dynamic interpretations.
And I'm also thinking about
the materiality, so not just
referencing materials,
but also using materiality
as a signifying
strategy, so to create
multilayered folkloric
vernaculars to translate
scientific imagery
that is not static.
That's absolutely spot on.
Maybe like an informed
[? material ?]
vernacular, I would say.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--two things come to mind.
Yeah, this is
really what made me
converge on this
obsessively on interglot.
There's something
there, that I feel
that it has so many
dimensions in which we
could mine that metaphor.
Yeah, do you know--
My dream--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--statement of
the forked tongue?
I just want to put that
in there because that's
such a nice word for that.
While you have like
one-layered imagery,
you could fork it all
the time, forked tongues.
My dream for the way that I want
to go about this problem just
personally is--
this is the dream--
for every single
scientific discovery,
I could tell a story
about it, put it
into kind of a story form.
Because that is a non-visual
but very universal, kind
of folkloric, I heard.
I would be able to also
create a visual piece of art
around it, which is great.
And I'll also be able
to gamify it somehow.
That's one we didn't talk about.
It's another-- that's
another largely universal.
That's debatable.
I'll ask the
anthropologist in the room
whether or not
[? gamification ?]
is truly universal.
But I think there are
certainly arguments of that.
And so what I'm saying is,
I wonder if this interglot,
if all of these different
possibilities could live.
I don't see these
things in contention.
I think you can have
something kind of raw
at the middle of an
interglot, but it
can be adapted for
kind of whatever
the constraints, or
needs, or availabilities
of where that science needs
to be kind of translated.
We're running toward the
hour, but I want quickly
to give you guys an
opportunity to ask
each other
super-quick questions.
I mean, what kinds
of things came up
for you that we
haven't surfaced yet,
just so we can offer something.
Go ahead.
I mean--
Yeah, just for
me-- oh, go ahead.
No, no, go ahead.
Well, just for me,
doubling back to looking
at Rosa's presentation and
reading Rosa's work, just
how the basic question of
how we're even imagining
the relationship
between the information,
and often in the individual
sense of your work,
Rosa, how that comports
very neatly over to biology.
I mean, we aren't even thinking
about the problem of what
a phenotype is correctly,
which is why we're never,
ever getting after very neat
and clean genetic answers
for even diseases.
I mean, we're getting
interesting information,
but it's not as
simple as we thought.
And it's in part
because we're thinking
about the problem
in a broken way,
not unlike the way that you've
constructed your resolution
kind of problem in the
visual and in other contexts.
So that's just something I
kind of highlighted that I
thought really was interesting.
I'll stop there now.
But I think we have to
give props to Stefan here,
because I think what he
did is he created a really
nice panel in which Priya, me,
and you, we kind of have this--
I wouldn't say like
"flow" between us,
but of course, Priya is
researching a particular thing.
And so she's finding,
trying to find models,
whereas you're like
reverse engineering,
also, to see how things
have become something.
And then me personally, I'm
trying to establish this tool
to see how we can
make things, or how
you can make maybe problems
and redefine ways of seeing.
So I see that that's
how that came about.
Yeah.
So thank you, Stefan.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
I mean, I guess
the only question
that I had was about
how do we-- we are all
united in our ambition
of what we want, I think,
for science, society,
culture, and so on.
But I'm curious about should
we really aim for universals?
This is the question that I--
and I would really
like Stefan to weigh
in as an anthropologist,
where you have looked
at multiplicity,
and you're not as
focused on finding the
explanation for something,
right?
Oh, that's a difficult question,
Priya, thank you for that.
Yes, I mean, so much in cultural
anthropology is precisely
about demonstrating
that things that people
think of as universals are
parochial and have histories.
And there's various
ways into that.
We can think about
histories of color.
We can think about histories of
genes as holding information.
And we can unwind
all of those things,
and unwind the universality
of those claims.
And we are winding
up the time, I see.
There's a clock
flashing at me here.
And I just want to
thank you, all three,
so much for this incredibly
wonderful conversation,
and for the superb--
just absolutely
superb-- presentations
you recorded for us here
at [? CAST ?] at MIT.
And just thank you
so much, everybody.
No, thank you to all of you.
Thank you.
That was absolutely--
--a real privilege.
Amazing.
A pleasure, yeah.
Privilege, indeed.
Thank you.
And thank you, Stefan.
Are we off camera now?
Is this the lunchroom?